[Musique]
la levée progressive du confinement se
fera en trois étapes a annoncé emmanuel
macron la première dès samedi 28
novembre avec notamment la réouverture
des commerces dits non essentiels
chargement vent devant le tribunal de
versailles le 7 décembre l'ex préfet des
yvelines de 2015 à 2018 comparaîtra pour
des accusations de détournement de fonds
publics et faux documents
alors qu'il était encore en fonction
l'enquète avance sur l'assassinât de
samuel pâti à conflans sainte honorine
quatre nouveaux collégiens ont été mises
en examen cette semaine dont trois pour
complicité d'assassinats terroristes
36e campagne d'hiver des restos du coeur
lancé en pleine crise sanitaire et
économique
les 26 centres du territoire s'attendent
à recevoir des bénéficiaires
supplémentaires cette année
manifestation ce 26 novembre à
versailles d'une cinquantaine d'agents
du secteur social et médico social
ces personnes s'estiment oubliés du
ségur de la santé elles demandent entre
autres une hausse de 183 euros de leur
salaire mensuel cinquième édition du sk
business dès cette année en 100% virtuel
la convention d'affaires de saint
quentin en yvelines a réuni 400
entreprises et 500 participants
et puis saint quentin en yvelines perd
son ancien vice-président à la culture
pierre sellin course est éteint et
quatre dans trois ans il a été le maire
communiste de la verrière pendant 29 ans
jusqu'en 2012
un hommage lui sera rendu prochainement
[Musique]